arthrose
mesdames messieurs et tous les autres
aussi bonsoir
quelle année pour le cinéma français qui
une fois de plus a réussi à nous faire
rêver
cette année encore on a vu de l'action
du mystère des rebondissements des
coeurs brisés des éclats de rire des
larmes du spectacle et là je ne parle
que des réactions à l'article de vincent
maraval
enfin la famille du cinéma ressemble à
une vraie famille les parents
s'engueulent les fistons ses tripes et
le tonton s'est barré à moto sifflet de
la vodka avec ses potes une famille
normale quoi c'est normal me direz vous
c'est l'année du normal mais ce soir
l'amour va l'emporter
ensemble nous allons plonger dans le
coeur du cinéma français pour essayer
d'apporter des réponses aux questions
qui nous brûle tous les lèvres patrick
bruel va-t-il réussir enfin à se faire
un prénom
michael haneke sera-t-il le prochain
gouverneur de californie
quant à noémie se dépassent est-ce que
camille il redouble
si françois est au second alors qu'il
est à l'image
qui a eu le final cut sur marie
antoinette
si denis lavant ok mais combien et enfin
pourquoi at on retrouvé les jambes de
marion cotillard en roumanie dans une
barquette de lasagnes surgelées pour
l'heure tous et mystère reste entier
enfin ce soir vous êtes là comme
toujours il y aura des gagnants il y
aura des perdants mais vous ressortirez
tous avec le sourire en gardant en tête
ce constat lucide de groucho marx
personne n'est jamais tout à fait
mécontents devant l'échec d'un ami